Irving, we have a site that ranks very well organically, about 80 gross leads a month,
but about 75% of leads are spam calls, web forums, still 20 qualified leads. A business
owner is not digging it, misses some calls, and when he does pick up, it's spam calls.
Any suggestions for a situation like this? I told him to pick up every call, follow up every call,
because the call he misses out might be a juicy one that he'll miss out on.
I don't know what you're using. I know with some of these tools, you can blacklist some of these,
but I'm going to be honest, I've had this happen a lot, and I think not a lot, but it had to happen
a few times. I think when you're buying tracking numbers, you just got to realize that sometimes
you get a shitty one, and sometimes it's a number that's been spammed out, and so there have been a
couple instances where we've just had to change the phone number, and it sucks because you have
to go and update it on your GMB and the whole thing, but what I would do first is try and do
the blacklisting thing and see if you can figure that out, and then if you absolutely have to,
I think it's worth it long term to just let the business owner say, hey, we're going to have a
little bit of a decrease in calls, but we're getting a new phone number to get rid of this issue,
and now every call that comes in should be a good one. Now you've got to go update your citations
and all that good stuff, but nonetheless, I think that it's worth it at some point.